Brothers and sisters, before the video
starts, today we might win 10,000 extra
dollars for our salah project. All we
need is 1,000 people to give £1. Enjoy
the video. The link is there.
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to is
if you want to support someone like me
in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just £100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate now.
Asalam
alaikum brothers and sisters and dear
friends. I found this out from Zetto uh
I think that's how it's pronounced from
me Hassan's media platform and I was
shocked that Mo Salah and Gary's
interview was canceled by the BBC for
what reason though. Let's find out in
let's hear it from Man himself. Did the
BBC recently cancel a scheduled
interview apparently between Gary Lka
and Liverpool star Mosul over the over
concerns that the pair might talk about
Gaza, right? Um a decision that you
called beyond pathetic on social media.
What do you make of the BBC's coverage
of this
genoc and and I was there for the launch
for the few days and stuff like that. I
have recently been and I haven't replied
to the email yet. I just got it today to
ask me to go on the BBC news. Uh and
there is not a hope in hell of me going
on the BBC uh at the moment and I have a
magnificent relationship with the BBC. I
would not have had a career on TV
certainly without the BBC. They've been
incredibly kind to me. The UK have been
incredibly kind to me and my career. I
will be eternally grateful as the as the
US has as well. Uh, however, uh, BBC
News, uh, is just it's jaw-dropping.
It's like watching a movie with a BBC
News uh, insert in it. And I can't
believe what I'm seeing. It's it's what
was it? Paul Krugman talked about the
uh, the tyranny of Edenhandedness. I
think it the first time I'd read he he
he'd use that phrase. Um, yes, this
excuse of impartiality. Uh, and if I may
borrow a a striking metaphor, are we
saying due to impartiality that if this
was 1944, 1945 when we discovered the
horrors of Awitz, would we be contacting
Heinrich Himmler for his take on the
genocide because that's what's going on
now. It's I I find it
astonishing. I mean, I'm laughing, but I
should be crying. It is. It's a tragic
scene that we're in where, as you say,
people want to be evenhanded in a
genocide. You don't even have to go back
to World War II. I don't think the BBC
wait for the Russian military response
every time they report on a missile
attack on Keev. Um, I think they don't
trust the Russian military, rightly so.
But for some reason, the Israeli
military gets a pass. And this is,
brothers and sisters, reported in many,
many news outlets. I mean, let me just
show you guys a couple inshallah. Yeah.
So, this is one of those like, subhan
Allah. Look at this. BBC cancels Gary
Link's final interview with Muhammad
Salah over concerns that they will speak
about Gaza, an atrocity that's happened.
They are afraid. But if Russia was to
attack Ukraine for a split second, no
problem at all. No problem at all,
inshallah. And here's another um uh
video you can see for yourself in um
clearly stating that look that the BBC
actually done this. Can you believe
this? Let's watch it for ourselves in
this. Another quick video. Gary Lker's
final BBC interview with Muhammad Salah
was reportedly cancelled over concerns
that the former pundit would discuss the
war in Gaza with the Liverpool star. The
England legend announced that he would
step back from the broadcaster for good
after becoming embroiled in controversy
for sharing an Instagram story about
Zionism featuring a rat, an anti-semitic
trope used by the Nazis to characterize
Jewish people as vermin. However,
according to The Sun, Lica was believed
to be primed for a sitdown with Salah,
but the interview was cancelled without
warning amid fears that he would discuss
the ongoing conflict in the Middle East.
Meanwhile, the BBC were contacted for
comment by the publication and shared
the following statement. The interview
was cancelled because it planned to air
after Gary's last match of the day. I
mean, there you go, guys. I What could
you make out of that? Subhan Allah. That
they have canceled in Mo Salah and Gary
Linka. One's a Muslim, one's a
non-Muslim. You have people like Dave
Smith who's a Jewish person, who's a
Jewish man and all of them, they have
been attacked because of objective news
to say that what's going on in Gaza is a
genocide. This is wrong. You can't make
this stuff up guys. It's genuinely you
think to yourself and rightly so that
guy mis was interviewing. It's like in
the 1944 1945 going to one of Hitler's
left and right hand man and asking him
for explanations, you know, and give lay
here not to be impartial. Brothers and
sisters, they would never do this. And
you can see the hypocrisy. That's why
justice is one of the most important
things in Islam. Justice is the most
important thing in Islam. And this is
something it's not just insulted Muslims
but even non-Muslims. And even even says
those even kufur non-Muslims who act on
justice, Allah will give them victory
over the Muslims who are injust. Why?
Because the greatest injustice in this
life is the associate partner brother
and sisters. And that follows with other
injustices. Subhan Allah. I couldn't
believe it. And subhan Allah. And we
hope people like Mosah carry on um
speaking more. I don't know if he's he's
speaking about it, but he should do more
about it inshallah. Subhan Allah. Says
the shame on you be received and big up
to Gary Lar. May Allah bless and
preserve you guys.